محمد حسين فنانه السودانيه مخيم بسببها
الحزن على كل المنصات في السودان بعد
الاعلان عن وفاتها الروايات حول الوفاء
متضاربه في كلام عن وفاتها بفضيه في كلام
ثاني عن وفاتها رميان بالرصاص وبعد مشاده
كلاميه مع مسلحين وفي كلام عن رصاصه طائشه
الفنانه الشابه الراحله عشرينيه وهي من
شمال كردفان ونشات وترعرعت هناك ومن بعدها
انتقلت لام درمان لتكمل تعليمها في مجال
الاقتصاد والاداره وتوفت هناك في منزلها
فجر السبت ويمكن اكثر ما هو مؤلم في قصه
شادن انه اشتهرت بترديد الاغنيات الثراثيه
والثوريه والداعيه للسلام والرافضه للحرب
وغنيها لها رواج كبير بين الشباب غير
التفاعل الكبير اللي صار على تويتر على
خبر وفاتها وترحم الملايين عليها كثار
الدواخر منشور لي الراحله واللي كان على
فيسبوك وفي كانت بتشكو من الاوضاع الصعبه
وبتتكلم عن النهب والجوع والرعب وقالت في
اخر البوست لو متنا حنموت بكرامتنا
واخلاقنا وما حنقابل ربنا شايلين حق مو
حقنا
من الخرطوم معنا الصحفي في قناه العربيه
شهدي نادر اهلا فيك معنا شهدي ايش بنعرف
يعني في تضارب في الروايات ايش القصه مثلا
اللي تقدر تقول انها يعني قد تكون الادق
نعم
بحسب ما فائده مع فادنا احد افراد اسرتها
تحدثنا معها معه قبل قليل قال لنا بانهم
كانوا يتواجدون على منزلهم كانوا يشاهدون
بعض بعض الاشتباكات التي كانت تجري على
مقربه منهم هي تسكن في مدينه ام درمان
وتحديدا في حي الهاشماب هو حي شرقه مباشره
تقع مستشفى الولاده ام درمان التي
التي تتواجد بها قوات الدعم السريع وشرقي
منها يقع مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون جنوبها
وجنوب هذا هذا الحي مباشره يقع على سلاح
الطبي الذي يضم خلفه سلاح المهندسين وعدد
من الاسلحه هي تسكن في تلك
المنطقه هذه المنطقه ظلت تشهد اشتباكاته
ومناوشات بشكل مستمر ما قاله لنا احد افرا
اسرتها بان ما جرى هو كان قضاء وقدر ان
جزء جزء من مغذوف سقط واعطالها هي البقيه
لم يصفهم اذى قال بانه لم تصب باي رصاصه
كما يتم تداوله انه لا يوجد استهداف او
عمل شخصي راى انه يجري هو كان محضر قضاءه
القدر
طيب وكيف ردت فعل الشارع السوداني
طيب شاهدي هل سامعني كنت بسالك عن رده فعل
الشارع السوداني طبعا احنا في تاخير في
وصول الصوت لك بس بحاول الان اتاكد اذا
سامعني اي تفضل
الشارع السوداني تلقى خبر وفاتها بحزن
كبير جدا شادي وجدت جماهيريه طاقيه في
السنوات التي
برزت فيها بداتك مقنيه وشاعره قنت
للسلام مظله تنبوظ الحرب انخرطت فيه ثوره
ديسمبر التي انهت نظام حكم الرئيس عمر عمر
البشير كذلك نالت شهره واسعه من خلال
تقنيها
بالايقاعات
التراثي التراثيه هنا في السودان قنه
المردوم قنه الله الطنبور قنه يعني قنت
بعدد من الايقاعات المحليه ظلت تنادي
السلام ظلت تنبض الحرب عرفت هنا في
السودان الحكامه هذا لقب اطلقوا عليها
جمهورها وهي في الغرفه السوداني تعني
المراه التي تقول الشعر وتمجد القيم
الفاضله منك ومن شجاعه ومن مروءه وخلافه
الشارع يعني تلقى هذا هذا الخبر بموجه حزن
كبيره جدا وسائط التواصل
الاجتماعي حزن كبير جدا على رحيلها كان
رايها واضحا منذ منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
بانها تقف ضد الحرب بشكل عام هي عاشر هذه
الحرب بين طفولتها في اقليم كردفان كما
ذكرتي في بدايه تعريفك هي عاشت هناك تعرف
ما معنى الحرب تذوقت ويلاتها لذلك هنا كان
رايها واضحا منذ البدايه بانها لن تدعم اي
طرف انها تقف ضد الحرب من حيث المبدا نحن
نشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه التوضيحات
وطبعا
رحم الله شادن وشكرا لك كان معنا من
الخرطوم الصحفي في قناه العربيه شهد نادر
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]